I really love your character I think
it's so good and that's why when I said
Jason mimo and da
Bautista you you can be doing all the
things that they're doing you you you
will have the movie career because you
have that and that's a charm and that's
something I believe that's innate and
something that you just have that you've
always had inside of you but now you've
gotten to do a role where you're not
just the [__] you know this guy
you're doing this now you're playing uh
a dynamic character that you just shine
and you don't even have it seems like
you're not even trying which I love
you're not overdoing it which could
easily be done and turn viewers off your
character stays true I mean he's also
you know he's it's a dangerous character
because um uh he's he's so stoic and in
his own head uh you know his mind
working like a computer all the time um
and he's so kind of
emotionally unavailable compared
compared to most most human beings it
could leave I mean my big fear was that
I would not be able to create an
interesting character for the screen
that people would be like bored out of
their mind watching the show because
this guy's not charismatic or
interesting enough because there's on
physically externally there's not a lot
going on until there's just until
there's an explosion of action that we
kind of look forward to but really he's
a rather still character um e externally
and uh I'm glad to hear you say that you
enjoy watching him so much you feel
those layers that are going on you know
but
um yeah it's uh it really is a dream
role um and it's one of those that I
just uh sometimes I do sit back and
think like I am so lucky um that this
role found me and I get to play a role I
feel like I was truly born to play hey
guys I'm doing another live podcast
downtown LA at the Regent Theater and my
special guest for January 24th is
Kristen Ritter Breaking Bad Jessica
Jones this is going to be a soldout
event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you with
Michael Rosen bomb with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so excited there are
others you know there's a lot of scripts
that we're a part of attached to right
now that are characters nothing like
Reacher that I cannot wait to explore
and showcase um but this this one I
think will always be like you know just
um the Cornerstone of of um my my career
yeah and I think that
um I I know for a fact that we talked
about you know you're you just mentioned
at your shoulder you were exhausted you
were doing all the things you were
stressed out of your mind the first
season and it was just like I I remember
talking to you at a con or something
you're like dude I don't I don't know if
I could I don't know if I can do this
man I don't know if I could do that I
mean this is genuinely like holy [__] uh
what changed from the first season to
sex sex season second season where yeah
the Sex season was a lot more laid-back
yeah a little more sexy uh but what
changed in the second season where
um a a lot a lot I mean look we you know
we I have a great team around me and you
know you mentioned uh like you mentioned
really enjoying the story and the show
and the character and his mannerisms and
that like the witty like smartass remark
he makes that kind of you just you're
waiting for him to tell his honest truth
and the th those things that you're
enjoying you're really enjoying the
minds of uh my the creative team that's
around me um Nick santor the showrunner
who does an unbelievable job bringing
the reacher to life that we know and
Ling the books um and it's difficult
adapting that to TV and he knows just
how to do it and I'm fed by him um you
know and Don Granger at Sky Dan and Dana
Goldberg at Sky Dance all you know all
the executive partners that are like
really making sure we're picking the
right books and all the you know
adapting it well for TV Sam Hill our
producing director um you know there are
people around us that people cannot
appreciate the way that I appreciate
them that are making Reacher what it is
for people to enjoy